so we've got a really relevant classic
interview this week my interview from
2014 - Joe Messina
last week we had a quarry for you about
how American Muslims are more tolerant
of and I know that that's not always the
right word to use but I'll use it here
tolerant of homosexuality than white
evangelical Christians in the US and we
sort of talked about is it possible that
being persecuted makes you more
empathetic to the persecution of other
groups and we jokingly said if that were
true you'd think Christians would be
really empathetic intolerant right now
because they believe that they are
actively persecuted in the u.s. even
though the evidence doesn't really bear
that out that is exactly what my
interview with Joe Massino was about in
2014 it is a very compelling interview
he believes that Christians are
suffering from persecution so that will
be our classic interview for this week
it's a doozy if you are sort of new to
the show over the last year or two
you've probably never seen this one I
enjoyed it when it happened and I think
I'm going to enjoy watching it again
with you let's take a look at it now I'm
joined today by la-based talk-show host
Joe Messina Joe you've never been on the
show before and it's great to have you
on always good to talk to new people you
know I wanted to start off this
interview by kind of summarizing this
op-ed that your publicist sent to me but
I don't think I can do it justice
because I don't know that I fully
understand it to be completely honest
with you I know that it was related to
when you said something about Christians
and then atheists on Twitter went crazy
so can you kind of sum up this this
op-ed so we can talk about it well which
which one would it be they do a couple
of week and and and I don't know exactly
which me this is the one where you talk
about how you do these Faith Fridays on
your radio show and you talk to people
and about various faiths and that when
you talk about a Christian being
persecuted Twitter lights up atheists
call in and they're upset about
something yeah
I get what I do every week I look like
you said I have a faith Friday section
which is I keep politics out of it and i
strictly deal with faith okay yeah all
kinds of faith I've had Imams in pastors
rabbis Buddhist spiritualist so because
I'm a firm believer that even though I'm
rooted in my belief system a lot of us
try to talk about
as we do with politics but we don't
really know what the other person
believes we hear bits and pieces you
know in this hundred and forty character
world where we try to get our
information it's not very deep it
doesn't give you a whole bunch anyway
and what is the belief system you're
rooted in just so everybody knows I am I
am a non-denominational Christian okay
and so what happens is is every time I
talk about Christians being persecuted
not just Christians religious people
being persecuted but Christians
especially the APS get little irritated
with me okay and if I and if I poke at
the atheists and I don't mean that in a
negative way but in my estimation in my
my humble opinion
atheism is a religion or belief system
if you would because you have a belief
that nothing exists or most do I'm not
going to paint them all because some
will say to me I just I'm not so sure
there's a God well yeah I mean I think
that this is this is a I think this may
be a separate argument right atheist be
atheism being a religion or not is
something that I've talked about a lot
of my program it doesn't meet any of the
real criteria of following dogmatic
sacred beliefs it is a system of beliefs
that that that prides itself on evidence
over faith but I don't think that makes
it a religion but that's a separate
argument I'd say sure okay I give you
that so what happened is especially one
one day in particular as I was talking
about some of the the problems that
we've had where they want to put up
religious things at Christmas time or
other holidays during the year we had a
school that was lending itself out and
had a cross put up there for the Easter
celebration and they went Gracie I got
44 calls in an hour yeah most of them
from atheists who were very upset that I
would a say it was a religion that I
would be say the Christians were the
only ones being persecuted and my
comment at that point in time was well
wait a minute when are you persecuted
like Christians aren't certain holidays
holy days or whatever days you celebrate
or don't celebrate right and it drives
them nuts and I don't know why I still
say today and I know it's kind of cliche
is to say why is something you don't
believe in bother you so much well I
think that yeah I don't know that that's
a good barometer because I enter
extreme right-wing Christian guests all
the time and the mere mention from me
that some of their beliefs may be
completely unfounded beyond what is in
the Bible they get very offended with me
so I could make the same argument right
if they are so secure and avaible their
beliefs why is it why do they fly off
the handle when I question that so I
don't know that simply being upset at
your belief being questioned is a sign
that they are aren't valid but I agree
with you okay all right make sure bad
radio but hey look I am I am secure in
my belief system right you can't do
anything that's going to make me crazy
so what you're saying is there's no
evidence you could be presented with
that would make you change your beliefs
nope so that means that your beliefs are
completely disconnected from reality
right you're taking the Ken Ham point of
view that he did in the Bill Nye it
debate where Bill Nye was asked what
might change your beliefs and Bill Nye
said evidence and chem had Ken Ham was
at what would change but hold on a
second hold on Ken Ham was as what would
change your beliefs and Ken Ken Ham said
nothing how is that a rational worldview
if nothing would ever change it you you
when you say nothing will change let's
put it this way everybody has a belief
system okay again like you said not not
religious but everybody has a belief
system second oh I don't know you that
well but do you believe in evolution I
do believe in evolution okay and I could
say the same thing to you you can't
prove it and even evolutionists say they
can't prove it and when you take it to
the simplest level because you not you
but the generic to you like the pound on
Christians like me to say you guys don't
believe in science and you don't you
know you don't give any credence to
science yes we do we don't believe
science and came along in and of itself
we believe that God put those things in
order and we just call it science today
the problem and download oh yeah I don't
know I want to know where if this Big
Bang Theory that everybody talks about I
want to know whether the gases come from
if we had absolutely nothing and all of
a sudden two things came out of nothing
and then then gut together had an
explosion and sent this whole thing into
this beautiful universe that we have
you're telling me that takes no faith to
believe here's the thing though Joe
here's the thing I I want to get back to
this issue of the Christian oppression
for a second but okay just to address
this for a second this when when you
have holes in science science is a
cumulative process that builds on the
work of the previous scientists the fact
that not every question that can be
imagined has a scientific answer today
is not evidence of God or that sacred
texts are accurate and this is the
problem that there's been this pseudo
anti intellectualism that is connected
to literal religious beliefs in this
country that opens the door to saying
your lack of 100% certitude on an answer
to my questions is evidence that my God
exists exactly as I say my God exists
and that's just that's just bogus no
Mike my comment would be the fact that
there is more than just one or two holes
it's proof that you don't have it all
together in the scientific world and
there and for you to say that okay well
we can't explain what the gases come
from but we know it's real and we can't
explain an evolution where the
transitional fossils might be that you
can't find but we know that's real okay
and then you have this time period I
can't remember what it's called but you
have a time period of evolution where
all of a sudden all these species pop up
out of nowhere well there's no evolution
there so so to say that you've got proof
and we have to teach this as reality it
holds the same water as me saying I'm
going to teach God as reality no it's
completely different and you know you
and I aren't going to agree on this and
I know that but so what I want to get
back to is this the problem I think some
atheists have with with what you talked
about earlier which is talking about
Christian oppression and Christians
being discriminated against is this do
you think that discriminating against
someone for being black hypothetical is
exactly the same as someone whose
religion tells them that black people
are inferior to white people is
discriminated against if it's not legal
to have a sign
your doors saying we don't serve black
people in other words yet our is
anything under the guise of a religious
belief valid and completely immune from
criticism or would you call it
discrimination no matter what okay if
you want to the black and white thing
black person can't change their skin
color any more than then a gay person
can change their sexual or aldashin
that's a discussion for a different day
again that but not though because
there's no science at all that suggests
anyone chooses where you get if we're
talking about whether God exists or not
that's not the conversation today when
we're talking about Christians being
persecuted but but the gay issue is a
conversation we can have today right so
anyway let's get back to the a black
person cannot change their skin color
right and as far as persecution goes
towards blacks and I know what you're
getting at because I know other
talk-show hosts have had me on and said
the same thing look unless you're a
study of the Bible it's easy to throw
out little catchphrases and things that
Christians have said over the years if
you really think that I'm going to sit
here and tell you that everything that
comes out of a Christians mouth is true
and real and all of that it's not you
would be crazy to say that I'm glad
you're saying that right alright so we
got we got Christians that blow up
abortion clinics in the name of God I
don't know what God you're talking about
it's not my gut my God doesn't tell me
to do that good
I got Christians out shooting abortion
doctors in the name of God my God
doesn't tell me to do that okay so we
we've got nut jobs we'll say in every in
every realm okay would you could we
agree on that we could agree on that in
the u.s. we see that yeah go ahead go
ahead yeah right so so as far as I think
the original question was you're talking
about you know refusing the service to
people and that kind of stuff
I think you can look at we're in a
country that gives you the freedom to
serve or not serve to do or not do so if
you come into my restaurant and I don't
want to serve you even though it's legal
I don't want to serve you because you
come in with the I don't know let's get
ridiculous for a minute all right it
looks like you haven't wash your hair in
25 years okay like that yeah I don't
want you in my restaurant I don't have a
right to do that well there are certain
protected classes of people right so
there are certain reasons into the same
way we have Employment
non-discrimination so so we could
certainly pick pick ones that are
protected and that aren't protected but
I think I don't want to miss state your
position Joe what you're getting at is
if it's based on a characteristic that
someone has chosen rather than something
they were born with you're okay with
discriminating in that sense if it's
based on something someone has chosen
you've said if you're born black so that
one you think is not a okay one but I
think someone has chosen what if you're
born with with the you've got one arm
shorter than the other you know some
people get all wigged out about physical
things that yeah the people are born and
not born with you know what you can't
change that there's nothing you can do
about that
and everybody deserves our right you
know the handicap the a da yeah right
the a BA that's great that's fine I'm
all for that everybody should have the
opportunity to be able to go to
restaurants and go to stores would be
able to move around I agree with you but
what about the thing that the
characteristics that are changeable it
sounds like you're more okay with saying
I don't want to serve someone who falls
under that umbrella yeah I should have a
right not to serve yeah some becomes in
a store with a shirt that says you know
blank you and the horse you rode in on
right what you know the obvious question
Joe becomes what is more arbitrary
self-professed
optional and not something you're born
with then religion Wow
well religion obviously the choice you
make right so if you walk in the door
and I'm in your restaurant and I decide
to bow my head and pray over my food and
guy walks up and says we'll have no
praying in here mmm
the difference between me and some other
peoples I'm not going to go sue him I'm
going to leave the food on the table I'm
going to leave it I'm gonna let my
Christian friends down here you know
this guy doesn't allow prayer and yeah
that's you personally though religion is
a protected class in this country it is
not a protected class if it wasn't
protected class you wouldn't see all the
all the lawsuits and other things going
on in this country like those are not
those are your those are for imposing
religious beliefs on others it's back
this is exactly where we get into it
intolerance of discrimination is not
discrimination and I think that's the
crux of it Joe intolerance of
discrimination is not discrimination
okay
I mean look when you when you sit there
and you tell me I was listening to one
of your shows where your attack every
Monday yeah was at the Arkansas Supreme
Court justice good we would say Alabama
I think I'm sorry Alabama wouldn't take
the Ten Commandments off the I think it
was the front lawn at what given inside
yeah but a bunch of hypocrites at the
Supreme Court who also have the Ten
Commandments up on the wall so he can't
have them on the front line but the
Supreme Court can have on the wall
that's okay
all right well there's no story it's
been a real pleasure having you on Joe
we are we did go three minutes over
because it is such an interesting
conversation in the show here I would
love to have you back any time even if
we don't agree we've been talking to Joe
Messina la-based talk-show host
check out his show he has a politically
incorrect area going on in a studio so
I'm sure our audience will love it
thanks Joe thank you